so let's go to our first topic and we
heard kirsten earlier in the show laying
out his climate proposals so we're
asking would labor being in charge be
better for the planet so dave let's take
a look at what he said at 28 billion
pounds a year for the next decade to
tackle climate change there's also money
for green steel money for retrofitting
homes to make them more energy efficient
so does that sound good to you
yeah i think that labor would be an
amazing
government to forward the climate change
agenda um as we have the tories
currently now um we see that there's a
lot of talk about being climate leaders
but we're still yet to see them achieve
their own targets um this is an issue
and we need to start seeing it as an
issue um i think that kiyosama today
within his speech speaking upon things
like having a clean air act um having a
um like bringing in insulation which
seems to be really hot topic amongst the
protests that's been happening um i do
think that having the labour party and
what they're promising could be really
amazing for this country but then also i
think there's a little bit of hesitance
around their labour party as a at the
moment they're very fractured party um
and i think they need to really work on
some of the internal um conflicts and
come together so they are stronger and
better for the next election
sam you're a conservative so what do you
make of that criticism that the tories
are all talk and no action and that
would you agree that labour's plans do
look better for the planet
well i disagree firstly the um the
conservatives are all talking no action
yes there are some strong targets that
the government's put in place but you
have also seen alongside that deep
emissions cut particularly in the power
sector where coal has gone from over 30
of our electricity mix down to almost
zero in the space for a few years
renewables have ramped up we've got the
biggest offshore wind sector in the
world so i don't think that's the fair
criticism in terms of labour's proposals
i actually do think that there is a case
for more spending on climate change and
i hope that the chancellor addresses
that in the comprehensive spending view
i think it will help people install
insulation which will cut their energy
bills i think it could also help us get
a first mover advantage in number of
green industries but i disagree that
this should be a predominantly publicly
financed and funded transition i think
there's a huge wall of private capital
out there waiting to invest in green
industries and green infrastructure look
at the offshore wind sector for example
which has been built predominantly
through private finance i worry that
with some of labor's proposals you risk
crowding out the private sector you
don't fully capitalize on the innovation
the cost reductions which only come from
private sector competition and i think
that's why the conservative approach was
there's still more to do and i'm not
here to say the government's yet on
track to his targets i think that
approach ultimately is the one that will
get us to net zero quickest and with
popular consent okay dave what do you
make of that
well i just don't i also i don't really
agree with you
i think that um within the last um
reports that we got from the climate
change committee it is showing that the
government is not on their targets and
they are seriously lacking behind um i
do worry about putting the hands of our
future in business as we can see um
there is a lot of issues with business
not being accountable for the climate
catastrophes they are called saying um
and there needs to be really strong
government in this i believe
and what about some of the other
criticisms sam that's levelled at the
government at the green homes grant that
was scrapped after six months the the
fact that the campbell oil field could
get the go-ahead
the
lack of ban on new oil and gas projects
do you think that's undermined the
government's green credentials and how
important is that given that we're going
into cop in november with the uk's hosts
well on the on the green homes grant i
mean it's important to note that that
was introduced as a short-term stimulus
measure to create jobs and get the
economy going post-covered there is a
need desperately for more energy
efficiency funding as i as i said and i
hope that in the comprehensive spending
review and the heating building strategy
which the government is shortly due to
publish there will be more funding to
give households vouchers and other
incentives to insulate their homes that
i i agree that is a missing piece at the
moment um but i don't think it was right
to look at the green homes grant for for
doing that project within that policy
in terms of oil and gas you know we are
going to see a decline in oil and gas
use as a result of our net zero target
the climate change committee thinks
about 70 by 2015 i do therefore think we
need to look at you know how the oil and
gas sector is going to wind down and how
we need to instead ramp up green energy
to take its place um you know the
government has said there's going to be
this climate checkpoint and which will
make sure that any new oil and gas
licenses
are compatible with our targets and i
think that's the key we need to get that
policy right so that we are still in
line with our net zero target even even
if there is going to be ongoing oil and
gas which we do still need